(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre os débitos
de condomínio e débitos de IPTU em um
leilão excrediticial.
Em um leilão excrediticial, pode ser que o
edital contenha a previsão de que os débitos
de condomínio e IPTU, mesmo anteriores à data
da arrematação, sejam de responsabilidade do arrematante.
Pode ser que o edital disponha que os
débitos de condomínio e IPTU anteriores à data
da arrematação sejam de responsabilidade do vendedor, isto
é, do credor fiduciário que está realizando aquele
leilão.
Então, aqui eu vou repetir mais uma vez
o mantra de um arrematante de sucesso, leia
o edital com muita atenção.
Então, se você estiver interessado em participar de
um leilão excrediticial, você vai ler o edital
com muita atenção e você vai ter que
verificar qual é a parte do edital que
fala sobre os débitos anteriores à data da
arrematação, os débitos do imóvel, quais são os
débitos do imóvel, via de regra, são os
impostos que incidem sobre o imóvel e o
condomínio, se for o caso, se esse imóvel
ficar localizado num condomínio.
Então, geralmente, IPTU e condomínio são os débitos
do imóvel e esses débitos podem acompanhar o
imóvel ou não, vai depender daquilo que o
edital dispõe sobre essas dívidas, se essa responsabilidade
vai ser do arrematante ou não sobre débitos
anteriores à arrematação.
Então, você deve ler o edital com atenção
e encontrar a parte que fala sobre esses
tipos de débito.
Em alguns casos, você vai precisar de atenção,
porque pode ser que mesmo que o edital
coloque a disposição que os débitos de condomínio
e IPTU anteriores à data da arrematação serão
de responsabilidade do arrematante, nem o edital, nem
o leiloeiro apresentam o valor desses débitos.
Então, interessado em arrematar aquele imóvel, vai ter
que buscar qual é o valor dos débitos.
E aqui, vou explicar como é que você
pode buscar o valor desses débitos.
Se for débito condominal, você pode, com a
ajuda do Google, procurar o telefone daquele condomínio.
Isso porque a grande maioria dos condomínios possuem
telefone em suas portarias.
Então, você pode entrar em contato com essa
portaria e pedir ao porteiro que ele te
passe o telefone da administradora daquele condomínio.
Essa informação é bem tranquila de conseguir diretamente
no prédio, porque os porteiros eles sempre sabem
o número da administradora do condomínio.
Afinal, se eles se depararem com algum problema
durante o seu horário de trabalho, eles vão
ter que acionar algum responsável para resolver esse
problema.
E na maioria das vezes, esse responsável que
eles acionam é exatamente a administradora daquele condomínio.
Então, fique atento a isso e tente buscar
o telefone desse condomínio no Google, o telefone
da portaria desse condomínio no Google.
Caso você não consiga encontrar o telefone dessa
portaria no Google, compareça ou faça comparecer a
portaria desse condomínio para pedir essa mesma informação.
Quanto aos débitos de IPTU, a maioria das
prefeituras municipais informatizaram o sistema de busca por
débitos de IPTU, então você consegue fazer isso
diretamente da internet.
Basta que você tenha o número de inscrição
municipal daquele imóvel ou essa inscrição municipal também
é chamada por algumas prefeituras de inscrição fiscal
do imóvel.
Com esse número, você vai procurar no site
da prefeitura o campo em que a prefeitura
disponibiliza para consulta através do número do imóvel
e vai pesquisar como é que você vai
ter acesso ao número desse imóvel.
Geralmente, a inscrição municipal de um imóvel ou
sua inscrição fiscal consta na própria matrícula daquele
imóvel, então com a ajuda da matrícula do
imóvel, você pode procurar esse número e realizar
a consulta no site da prefeitura do município
onde aquele imóvel fica localizado.
Algumas matrículas não vão trazer o número dessa
inscrição municipal, então você não vai ter acesso
ao número dessa inscrição municipal procurando na matrícula
do imóvel.
Primeiro passo que eu te recomendo é que
você entre em contato direto com o leiloeiro
para que o leiloeiro possa te informar o
número dessa inscrição.
E aqui entra uma observação muito importante, o
leiloeiro é sempre uma pessoa muito próxima de
todos os interessados em arrematar.
Como eu já falei anteriormente no curso, o
leiloeiro ganha uma comissão sobre o valor da
arrematação, então para o leiloeiro é interessante sempre
o maior número de competição no imóvel, porque
quando um imóvel tem competição, automaticamente o preço
que aquele imóvel vai ser arrematado vai subir,
então com preço maior, o leiloeiro ganha mais,
afinal a comissão dele incide no preço final
da arrematação, então o leiloeiro é sempre muito
receptivo a falar com todos os interessados em
arrematar o imóvel, então você pode usar o
telefone que o próprio leiloeiro disponibiliza, ou o
site do leiloeiro, ou até se você quiser
comparecer fisicamente no escritório daquele leiloeiro, eu uso
sempre o telefone e pelo telefone eu consigo
essas informações.
Então recapitulando, o número de inscrição municipal ou
inscrição fiscal, depende de como o município daquele
determinado imóvel vai chamar esse número, geralmente está
na matrícula, existem matrículas de imóveis que não
tem esse número, então o primeiro passo que
eu recomendo é que você entre em contato
com o leiloeiro para que o leiloeiro te
informe o número de inscrição municipal desse imóvel,
pode ser que o leiloeiro, antes do leilão,
ele tenha acesso a algum outro tipo de
documentação que contenha esse número, então ele pode
passar tranquilamente para todos os interessados em arrematar
aquele imóvel, o objetivo do leiloeiro é que
todo leilão tenha o máximo de competição possível
porque isso aí aumenta a comissão que ele
vai ganhar ao final daquele leilão.
Se o leiloeiro também não tiver o número
da inscrição municipal e o site da prefeitura
não te permitir fazer essa consulta pelo CPF
do responsável tributário, como é que você teria
o CPF do responsável tributário?
Na própria matrícula, como a gente já falou
anteriormente, a matrícula ela traz todos os dados
de todas as pessoas que já foram proprietárias
daquele imóvel, todas as dívidas que aquele imóvel
já teve e alguns outros dados sobre o
imóvel, como metragem e outras coisas do tipo.
Então, a matrícula ela vai te apresentar o
CPF do responsável tributário, então você poderia, se
o site dessa prefeitura do imóvel que você
estiver interessado, permitir consultar com o CPF.
A grande maioria dos sites das prefeituras não
permitem a consulta com o CPF, só permitem
a consulta com a inscrição municipal, então se
você não tiver na matrícula o número dessa
inscrição, se o leiloeiro não tiver como te
passar o número dessa inscrição, a forma de
você conseguir levantar os débitos desse imóvel vai
ser comparecer pessoalmente à prefeitura do município onde
esse imóvel fica localizado.
Você pode comparecer pessoalmente ou você pode pedir
para que alguém te represente e compareça, vai
ficar a seu critério o que for melhor.
Mas saiba que sempre que um edital de
um leilão colocar à disposição que débitos de
condomínio e IPTU, mesmo anteriores à data da
arrematação, serão de responsabilidade do arrematante, e mesmo
que o edital não apresente o montante dessas
dívidas e nem o leiloeiro apresente o montante
dessas dívidas, o arrematante deve correr atrás do
montante dessas dívidas.
Por quê?
Porque o edital foi bem claro falando que
essa responsabilidade vai ser do arrematante.
Então você precisa fazer o levantamento para você
estipular qual é o lance máximo que você
pode dar naquele imóvel e até para você
averiguar se aquele imóvel é um imóvel interessante
ou não para ser arrematado.
Imagina que aquele imóvel esteja com uma dívida
muito alta de condomínio e IPTU.
Isso pode impactar diretamente no seu interesse ou
não por arrematar aquele imóvel.
Então faça essa busca da forma como a
gente já falou aqui nessa aula.
Um outro ponto sobre débitos de condomínio e
IPTU.
É inegável que vai existir a responsabilidade do
arrematante pelos débitos de condomínio e IPTU a
partir da data da arrematação.
Isso não precisa nem ficar claro no edital
porque isso é óbvio.
A partir da data que a pessoa arremata,
ela já tem direito sobre aquele imóvel e
como direito sobre aquele imóvel, ela vai ter
que pagar as custas daquele imóvel.
Então as custas do imóvel são as parcelas
de IPTU mensal e os débitos condominais mensais
se for o caso de um imóvel localizado
dentro de um condomínio.
Então é importante que você faça também uma
pesquisa prévia para saber qual é o valor
daquele condomínio, qual é o valor daquele IPTU.
Por quê?
Porque isso também diretamente vai impactar no preço
máximo que você pode dar de lance.
Afinal, a gente já falou na aula sobre
explicação da calculadora que você vai ter débitos
até vender aquele imóvel, débitos mensais.
São débitos que existem em decorrência do imóvel,
que são débitos de IPTU e débitos de
condomínio.
Então é importante que você faça uma previsão
de quanto tempo você vai levar para vender
aquele imóvel depois de arrematar e calcule o
custo mensal daquele imóvel para você multiplicar pelo
tempo que você acha necessário.
Eu falei que eu recomendo sempre que você
calcule 12 meses dessas dívidas.
Então você pega o total do IPTU, o
total do condomínio mensal e multiplica por 12
meses.
Assim você terá uma margem aproximada do que
você vai gastar até a venda daquele imóvel.
E aí você pode ficar com a pergunta,
se eu vou arrematar um imóvel, eu vou
ser o responsável por pagar débitos de IPTU
e condomínio a partir da data da arrematação?
E se eu não estiver na posse do
imóvel?
Porque se o imóvel estiver ocupado, vai levar
um tempo para a desocupação daquele imóvel.
Pode ser que eu não consiga um acordo
com o ocupante daquele imóvel, que eu tenha
até mesmo que recorrer ao Poder Judiciário para
desocupar aquele imóvel.
Durante esse tempo, eu também sou o responsável
por pagamento dessas dívidas de IPTU e condomínio?
Sim, você como o novo proprietário daquele imóvel,
você é o responsável pelas suas dívidas de
condomínio e IPTU.
O que não significa que você não possa
cobrar de quem está ocupando o imóvel durante
o período que ele está ocupando o imóvel.
A Lei nº 9.514 é clara em
falar que o ocupante do imóvel, o devedor
fiduciário, é responsável pelos débitos do imóvel até
a efetiva emissão na posse.
Isso é, até a efetiva desocupação do imóvel.
Então você pode cobrar o valor mensal de
IPTU e condomínio durante o período que o
imóvel estava ocupado por outra pessoa que não
você.
Como é que você vai fazer essa cobrança?
Essa responsabilidade é do arrematante, de pagar desde
a data da arrematação o IPTU e o
condomínio.
Mas a lei diz que o devedor fiduciário
deveria pagar para você não correr o risco
de esperar depois uma cobrança do devedor fiduciário
e nesse meio tempo o condomínio daquele imóvel
ou até a prefeitura possam mover um processo
contra você por essas dívidas que vão existir
da data da arrematação até a emissão na
posse, o que eu recomendo é que você
pague esses débitos.
Você vai pagar para você não ter nenhum
tipo de surpresa contra um processo de condomínio
ou um processo da prefeitura para cobrar IPTU.
E depois que você pagar, você vai cobrar
tranquilamente esse valor durante o período em que
o ocupante ou o devedor fiduciário estava naquele
imóvel.
Não é um empecilho você pagar para depois
você receber aquele valor, é o recomendado, porque
se a prefeitura ou o condomínio for cobrar
o débito de alguém durante o período necessário
até realizar a emissão da posse, ele vai
cobrar do proprietário e você é o proprietário.
Então nesse eventual processo que um condomínio ou
que a prefeitura possa mover contra você, você
não vai conseguir jogar a responsabilidade no devedor.
Aquela responsabilidade de pagar o tributo ou a
despesa condominial é sempre do proprietário.
Então o proprietário vai ser processado, para você
não ser processado, pague esses valores pontualmente e
depois você cobra do devedor fiduciante ou do
ocupante daquele imóvel.
Como é que você vai cobrar?
Na mesma ação de emissão na posse.
A gente já falou que a ação de
emissão na posse, ela vai servir para o
juiz deferir uma liminar para que com essa
liminar ocorra a desocupação do bem.
Na mesma ação de emissão na posse, o
arrematante poderia cobrar do devedor fiduciante a taxa
de ocupação.
A gente já teve uma aula específica sobre
taxa de ocupação e agora a gente está
falando também que nessa mesma ação, o arrematante
pode cobrar ainda débitos de IPTU e débitos
de condomínio, se for o caso, do devedor
fiduciante.
Então ele vai acumular todos esses pedidos na
mesma ação e o juiz, da mesma forma
como a gente já falou na aula de
taxa de ocupação, ele vai deferir a liminar
no começo do processo, deferir a liminar, nada
mais é do que antecipar os efeitos que
aconteceriam no final do processo e essa liminar
vai servir para desocupar o imóvel, somente para
desocupar o imóvel.
Ela não vai servir para condenar em taxa
de ocupação, débitos de IPTU e condomínio na
liminar.
Essa condenação desses valores que o arrematante adiantou
no caso de débitos de condomínio e débitos
de IPTU ou que o arrematante faz jus
a receber, como é a taxa de ocupação,
vai acontecer no final do processo.
Ao final daquele processo, o juiz vai condenar
que o devedor fiduciante pague essas quantias ao
arrematante, mas novamente eu falo, para que você
não tenha dor de cabeça, pague normalmente essas
quantias e depois, ao final do processo de
admissão na posse, você vai ter o direito
à restituição desses valores.
No modelo de petição inicial que eu disponibilizei
na aula de desocupação de um imóvel em
leilão extrajudicial, esse modelo já consta com o
pedido liminar para desocupação do imóvel, com o
pedido de taxa de ocupação e com o
pedido da restituição dos débitos de condomínio e
IPTU que o arrematante vai pagar até a
efetiva admissão na posse.
Basta que você, naquele modelo, preencha o seu
caso específico.
Por exemplo, o seu caso específico, o condomínio
custa R$ 500 mensais e o IPTU
tem uma parcela de R$ 100 por
mês.
Então você vai preencher esse modelo e ao
final o juiz vai levantar quanto tempo aquele
devedor fiduciante ficou naquele imóvel para que você
possa multiplicar essa despesa mensal pelo tempo que
o devedor fiduciante ficou naquele imóvel e esse
vai ser o valor devido a título de
condomínio e IPTU mensal que o arrematante pagou.
Então fazendo um resumo dessa aula, pode ser
que o edital do leilão extrajudicial contém a
previsão de que débitos de IPTU e condomínio
anteriores à data da arrematação serão de responsabilidade
do arrematante e mesmo com essa previsão pode
ser que nem o edital nem o leiloeiro
apresentem esse montante.
Cabe ao interessado em arrematar aquele imóvel fazer
o levantamento desses valores.
Como?
Condomínio, você vai tentar procurar o telefone da
portaria do condomínio no Google.
Localizando, ligue para a portaria, peça o telefone
da administradora.
Uma vez entrando em contato com a administradora,
informe que aquele imóvel está indo a leilão
e que você é um interessado em participar
daquele leilão e que você precisa saber o
montante de débitos de condomínio que aquele imóvel
apresenta.
E débitos de IPTU, você vai procurar na
matrícula do imóvel a inscrição municipal ou inscrição
fiscal daquele imóvel na prefeitura do município onde
ele fica localizado.
Caso não encontre, tente entrar em contato com
o leiloeiro.
Se o leiloeiro também não tiver essa informação,
peça para alguém comparecer ou compareça pessoalmente na
prefeitura naquele imóvel levando os dados do imóvel.
Dados, endereço completo, número do apartamento, se for
o caso, CEP.
E peça para a prefeitura te informar o
montante de débitos de IPTU daquele imóvel.
Pós arrematação, é indiscutível que os débitos de
condomínio IPTU mensal serão do arrematante, inclusive até
a efetiva emissão na posse, mas a lei
defende o arrematante e fala que o arrematante
pode cobrar esses valores do devedor fiduciante até
a efetiva emissão na posse, ou seja, até
a desocupação daquele imóvel.
Para que você não corra o risco de
ser processado pelo condomínio, de ser processado pela
prefeitura, você é o novo proprietário daquele bem
e como proprietário você é o responsável pelo
pagamento daquelas dívidas.
Pague aquelas dívidas normalmente mês a mês e
ao final do processo de emissão na posse,
você vai ganhar o direito de receber aquele
valor que você adiantou.
Como?
Isso tudo consta no modelo de petição inicial
da ação de emissão na posse que eu
disponibilizei na aula de desocupação do imóvel.